negativity is a multiple of four to
seven times more powerful than
positivity
so think about that if i say something
out loud it's 10x if it's negative it's
four to seven times more powerful so
when i say negative things out loud it's
40 to 70 times more likely that that
will happen or cause a result that won't
be good for me than if i just didn't say
anything
so as we were going into our second year
at alabama we were going into our first
year at florida state and we were
ultimately going into our second year at
the university of georgia we made a bet
what if we could just get our players to
not say stupid things out loud
what if we could just do that not teach
any element of positive thinking but
eliminate conversations about the heat
complaining about coaches complaining
about circumstances complaining about
situations verbalizing negativity but we
weren't going to lie to them and say hey
be positive we just taught them the data
and then what we did was some of the
things that you you noticed in the book
the stories in and around negativity are
incredible
tell us some bill buckner was one that
took my breath away
so so billy buckner who just passed away
recently was an incredible eight-time
gold glove a great baseball player for
the boston red sox
well he made a mistake in sports that
would be one of the biggest sport
bloopers in history and in 1986 he let
the game-winning run score on a ground
ball through his legs that ultimately
would give the mets the world series
now
i was just watching an espn e60 jeremy
shap story and i saw an interview that
was done in 1990 that resurfaced in 1995
where buckner was interviewed 12 days
before the world series and he said you
know the dreams are to win
you know to win the world series and the
nightmare would be for me to let the
game-winning run score on a ground ball
through my legs
you know and then ultimately that's
exactly what would happen now by saying
that out loud what did he do he didn't
make it happen but he increased the
probability
and this is what i want people to
understand your internal thoughts are
all over the place
i want to push on that yeah do you think
that he makes it more likely because
it's going to subtly influence his
behavior or because you're talking to
some magical deity that then says well
you said it and so i'm going to make it
happen i think that what he did is a
subconscious plant
by verbalizing it and knowing that it's
10 times more powerful he's planting it
in his subconscious he's not he doesn't
want it to happen but it becomes
something that's ultimately on his mind
and he gave it more power by verbalizing
it and then wasn't there somebody that
said i i worry that i'm gonna
retire and die at 40 of a heart attack
right so so pistol pete maravich a
basketball player i'll give you two
other examples but but he was
interviewed at 26 years old and he said
you know i don't want to play 10 years
of pro basketball and die at the age of
40 of a heart attack
well he played 10 years of pro
basketball in pasadena california died
of a heart attack at 40. there's another
great story that i saw
from a magazine called success unlimited
in 1973 a guy is hired to fix a
refrigerated box car in back of a train
he goes into the train he panics gets
himself locked inside the boxcar so now
he's pounding on the door there's
nothing to do he starts to panic and
thinks he's going to freeze to death he
finds a pen he starts writing down tom
what's going through his mind and he
writes down i'm becoming colder as
people one of the things we do to
ourselves is observe and report i'm not
playing well i'm having a bad day we're
having a bad quarter my marriage isn't
going well we observant report still
colder now he writes nothing to do but
wait half asleep i can hardly write
finally
he says these might be my last words and
i'll show you the article they open up
the boxcar many hours later and they
find him and he's dead but the
temperature inside the box car was 56
degrees that's so crazy the freezing
apparatus was broken there was plenty of
air in the boxcar there was no physical
reason for his death the best they could
say is somehow he talked himself into
dying and as you know the book covers
the psychogenic death in and around the
korean war
when the korean war one third of all
american pows died and they said that
one of the things that was done in the
pow camps was the negativity they
manufactured articles about the united
states being bombed they withheld all
positivity they didn't give them any
mail believe it or not there are like
regulations for pow camps throughout the
world
and ultimately they filled up these
healthy american soldiers with all this
doubt a a priest would end up calling it
give up itis
and healthy american soldiers over a
period of days would walk over to a
corner sit down and die of broken hearts
so negativity is the most powerful thing
we're combating look at our politics
today a positive message versus a
negative message it's no no no chance
have you ever read men's search for
meaning i haven't read that guys you're
gonna love it so man's searching for
meaning victor frankel in a conference
yes yes yes yes yes it's actually in
multiple if i remember right he was in
five different concentration camps yes
and ultimately um he says that he you
could tell within 72 hours when someone
was going to die because they would give
up yep and he said once they gave up
then it was a 72-hour clock they no
longer knew why they were fighting and
and they would just die
and he was like but the people that kept
a mental image of what they were
suffering for like what it was they were
gonna do once they got out for their
family for whatever
he said that they would push through and
it just i mean look there's obviously a
million and one reasons to die in a
concentration camp but the fact that
even in the concentration camp they
could go i 72 hours we can peg it right
because we've seen that person give up
right like that's just crazy to me
well and and and i just think
when when i think about
being seven years old in the tacoma golf
and country club and walking off the
golf course my dad you know everybody
call mr positive and this and that but
in fairness to my dad when he was raised
and he was teaching the only thing was
positive and negative so if you weren't
negative you had to be positive
but that just never made sense to me and
if we could just learn how to not be
negative how to not externalize negative
then ultimately that would help them
more than ever trying to be told to be
positive want to be happy build a life
not just the business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to stop the negative
self-talk
enjoy
rule number two focus on the good things
with jack canfield researchers estimate
that we think about 50 000 to 70 000
thoughts a day and then about eighty
percent of those thoughts are negative
now that's a crazy number
we spend so much time telling ourselves
that we're not good enough we're not
smart enough or not talent enough or
thin enough we tell ourselves that we
don't deserve the things we want or that
the things we want to have or to
experience will never happen and even if
they do they'll probably be
disappointing
our negative self-talk affects us in a
very powerful way
if we think something is possible we're
more likely to make the effort to
achieve it if we think it's impossible
we won't even bother trying
if we think we're a good person who
deserves to live a life we love we will
create that life but if we think we're
undeserving or not capable enough we
will sabotage our own efforts without
even realizing it
now studies show that your thoughts also
have a physical impact on your body
take polygraph tests commonly referred
to as lie detector tests for example
they demonstrate how your thoughts
directly influence your blood pressure
your muscle tension your temperature
your breathing rate your heart rate even
how much your hand swept now those are
some pretty significant physical
reactions to your thoughts
and when you experience the effects of
negative thoughts such as thoughts to
create the emotional states of fear
anger anxiety guilt shame or regret the
muscles in your body actually become
weaker
your stress levels go up you experience
changes in your biochemistry and hormone
levels and you may even suffer from
gastrointestinal or digestive problems
among other physical symptoms now
studies also show that negative people
tend to be more depressed and are
generally less satisfied with life
in contrast when you experience positive
thoughts you flood your brain with
endorphins which helps you relax so
you're more alert and centered not only
that positive thinking increases your
experience of pleasure while reducing
physical pain as a result you're far
more likely to be confident optimistic
and motivated to do whatever it takes to
achieve your goals
but for some people shifting their
negative thoughts to positive ones is
easier said than done
some people have a lifelong habit of
seeing the bad and everything including
themselves they might try to justify
their negativity by pointing out
everything bad that's happening in the
world and saying they're just being
realistic but in reality all they're
doing is mentally sabotaging themselves
now the good news is you are ultimately
in control of your thoughts because you
are the source of them
that means you can learn to consciously
choose to replace your negative thoughts
with positive ones that will make your
life better
you see not all negative thoughts are
the result of your inner critic run wild
there are other types of negative
thinking that if you can learn to
identify them and count them you can
create a happier more successful more
positive and more fulfilling life so to
help you do that today i'd like to share
five of the main types of negative
thinking that people do so you can
recognize them when they happen and then
consciously choose to replace them with
something more positive
the first is called always or never
thinking this is when you find yourself
thinking in terms of always
never every time everyone no one and so
on for example thoughts like i will
never get a raise or nobody cares about
me or i always screw up no matter what
this type of thinking is not only
detrimental to your happiness it's not
based in reality it's not true that no
one cares about you or that you will
never get a raise
well that last one might be true if you
never do the necessary work to get a
raise
but then you're the one who's creating
that situation which means that you can
change it it's not an absolute given
now the next type of negative thinking
is focusing on the negative i mentioned
this before it's when you're so busy
looking at everything that's bad in the
world you can't see the good but the
truth is life isn't all bad just as it
isn't all good it's a combination of
both there's a positive side and a
negative side to pretty much everything
and since you get to choose what you're
going to focus on why not choose to
focus on the positive i promise you it
will have a much better impact on your
life and your health if you do
now the third type of negative thinking
is called catastrophic predicting this
is when you imagine the worst possible
outcome in any situation and convince
yourself of its inevitability usually
without any real facts to back it up
a good example of this would be that you
begin to imagine that you're going to be
laid off from work or that north korea
is going to send a nuclear missile and
blow up los angeles where you live even
when there's no concrete evidence that
supports your prediction
even though the worst case scenario
rarely ever happens you act like it's
just a matter of time and you let it
dominate your thoughts and your actions
the truth is we never know what the
future holds and history shows that
worst case scenarios seldom come to pass
so why worry about something that hasn't
happened yet and most likely never will
you're much better off to simply focus
on what is actually happening in the
current moment and just stay focused on
that such as the task at hand
now the fourth type of negative thinking
is a sneaky one i'm talking about mind
reading this is when you tell yourself
you know what someone else is thinking
and it's always something bad did you
ever find yourself having an argument in
your head with someone you imagine them
saying all sorts of terrible things that
frustrate or anger you or that hurt you
and make you feel ashamed
that is mind reading in reality you have
absolutely no idea what that person is
thinking but you tell yourself that you
do and you let this false belief
negatively impact your relationships
remember most likely you aren't psychic
the only way you can ever truly know
what someone else is thinking is to ask
them and have an honest conversation
about it
that's also how you form deeper more
meaningful relationships now another
type of thinking you should be aware of
is guilt tripping this is when you focus
on everything bad you've ever done
everything that makes you feel guilty or
ashamed and you allow that to define
your perception of who you are
you tell yourself you're a loser and a
bad person and you don't deserve to feel
happy or achieve the success you're long
for
and so you give up before you even begin
i've seen people waste their entire
lives because of their feelings of guilt
over something they did decades ago
maybe it was had an abortion lost to
marriage due to their alcohol or drug
abuse created the traffic accident lost
soldiers under the command and battle or
spent time in jail or convinced
themselves that someone else's death or
suicide could have been prevented if
they had only acted differently
the thing is everyone including me has
done things they regret you shouldn't
allow that to define you
you have also done a lot of really great
stuff in your life
if you focus on the good things and
start to see yourself as a fundamentally
good person who has made some mistakes
but is also capable of achieving great
things you will open yourself once again
to a life of unlimited possibility
now here's your homework to complete
after watching this video
begin to listen to how you talk to
yourself and how you talk to others do
you focus on the negative and assume the
worst are you constantly tearing
yourself down do you think in terms of
always or never do you assume you know
what other people are thinking without
checking it out
every time you catch yourself thinking a
negative thought
simply say the word silently or out loud
cancel cancel you're telling your
subconscious mind to cancel that and
then consciously shift it into a
positive thought instead rule number
three be kind to yourself with mel
robbins your
sense of feeling like the effort is
worth it begins and ends with how
encouraging supportive and kind you are
to yourself you have to become aware of
it and you have to realize that
sometimes like the way you talk to
yourself like believe it or not it does
impact us and whether we want to admit
it or not i think sometimes people when
they're feeling so down about themselves
they have a hard time admitting that
something in their life is going wrong
because they just they're already
feeling so low that the idea of even
having something bring them even down
lower like scares the hell out of them
right yeah so so let's let's break this
apart let's let's role play here okay so
let's say um
you are
uh what was the sport that you played as
a kid
i tried to play all sports i wasn't very
good but i would say the the sport that
i was the most consistent with was
basketball okay
so
little doug
is on the basketball court
and
there's a foul
and doug is the uh person
that is selected to shoot the free throw
and little doug steps up to the
free-throw line
and then all of a sudden they call a
timeout
and you come running back to the huddle
what
would be the most
empowering
and encouraging
and motivating
thing
that your coach or teammates could do or
say
in order to help you perform and feel
your best when you step onto that line
like i believe in you and you're gonna
make it i believe in you and you're
gonna make it you got this
and then they send you back into that
game with a high five
right how would that make you feel
little nine-year-old doug
i'd feel pretty confident right now
how would little nine-year-old doug feel
if when you came back to that huddle and
you're about to go do this free throw
that
your teammates are like oh him he's a
piece of
have you he screws everything up are you
kidding me
what we're gonna wha oh my god well i he
shouldn't be the one that does
how would that make little dog feel
it would probably
obviously make me feel like i'm not
gonna make the shot so i even bother
correct
what you say to yourself matters
and we understand that
from a common sense perspective
but somewhere along the line
we have all stopped saying
you're going to make it you got this
and we've started saying you're a piece
of you're not good enough why even
bother
and when you send yourself into a
conversation into
a
presentation into
even typing up an email
when you start your day
by saying i look terrible
i screwed up again yesterday i hate my
life
that's not going to motivate you to
change it
and so your
sense of feeling like the effort is
worth it begins and ends with how
encouraging supportive and kind you are
to yourself
and you know we can also take this
little role play exercise and go
well
let's say you miss the shot
and
you come back to the sideline again
what could your coach say
or what would you want your coach to say
to help you get your
head back in the game
and to brush off the mistake that you
just made
like you did your best doug you'll get
them next time like get back in there
and i have a feeling you're gonna be a
positive contribution to the team yeah
that's right shake it off you did your
best you're gonna do it next time this
is how you win some you lose some let's
go now i need you to win some right i
believe in you
i think one of the the role plays that
we could maybe go into that i think is
pretty common with people is that they
acknowledge that they maybe have to
start talking to themselves to
themselves better but whatever they
start to say that's positive there's
this cognitive dissonance because they
just don't believe it right how do you
get somebody who for the last 10 to 15
years has just been completely
destroying themselves self-talk-wise
begin to build some consistency with
that so now that becomes a new habit
that they're talking to themselves in a
more positive way and they actually
believe it instead of just saying it
this is a phenomenal and really smart
question
if you have been trashing yourself for
10 years you do have a cognitive
dissonance you don't even hear it
anymore because that
negative you're a piece of you're not
good enough you screw everything up
first began as something you said
then it became a belief
your brain started to align with the
belief and it starts to become your
identity i always screw things up and i
want you to hear me loud and clear if
you are on social media and you ever go
to the discover page
on instagram or on tiktok or on any
platform
that social media
platform has
put together a mosaic
of content
that aligns with everything that you
consume in your feed that's that social
media platform on the discover page has
assembled a world on social media that
looks just like the stuff you're always
looking at
your brain works exactly the same
way one of the reasons why it is so
important for you
to identify how often you are trashing
yourself or being pessimistic
or you are being negative in your
attitude and unkind to yourself is
because as long as you think and speak
that
the discover page of your mind presents
a world
that matches to that negative dialogue
so that's why this is critical
the second thing that you need to do
because you're unconscious to it right
is
there are two things that are going to
work because just trying to speak kindly
often doesn't work because you have so
trained your mind that you think you're
not good enough that saying i'm good
enough doesn't work because your brain
literally looks at you like who are you
talking to like i'm
because
i can't be you
so there's two things that will help you
based on the research
the first one is journaling exercises
because there is
something that happens
when you create a new habit
where every single morning before you
look at that social media
you open up a blank page
and the way that i
journal is very simple
i always start by writing down five
things that i want
and i just let them flow through me what
are five things that i really want
and
it might be something small
it might be that
you know i i want a really cool new pair
of sneakers
it might be something big i really want
to feel happy
it might be something that is a feeling
like you know this this pandemic has
kicked the [ __ ] out of everybody
i am i am not immune from the feeling of
burnout or the feeling of languishing
the feeling of disconnection even from
self that that we can all feel when
you're isolated for this long and you're
remote for this long and you're stressed
out for this long and so
allowing yourself to write down five
things that you want i want to feel like
myself again
it allows the the things that you desire
to flow through the self-doubt and
through the negativity and through all
the crap that buries it and pushes it
down and it allows it to come to the
surface and the writing it down is
important because your mind is paying
attention
that discover page that your mind
creates pays attention
to what you say is important and if you
begin a new habit
of just starting your day with a blank
piece of paper and writing down five
things that you want
every day can be the same things every
day it can be different things every day
you just allow yourself to do this you
will start to build the skill
of being connected
to what you desire
you will start to develop a skill
of tuning out the self-doubt and tuning
into what you want and this is really
important because your brain is paying
attention and it doesn't require you to
talk to yourself it just write it on a
piece of paper the next thing that
you're going to do step two is write
down why you want these things
because if you have a negative
dialogue doug
you have for decades talked yourself out
of the things that you want
you have filled your heart and your soul
and your mind with all the reasons why
it's never going to happen
and so by starting every day with a new
habit write down five things that you
want and then write down why you want
these things you're developing a skill
of listening
to what you want instead of listening to
the self-doubt
that's step one that's one thing that
you can do
to fight decades of negative self-talk
the second thing that you can do is
every morning
after you brush your teeth
add a high five in the mirror to your
reflection to your morning routine
that will have
a shockingly powerful impact
on your negative self-talk
and the reason why it does is because
your brain watches you do it
and you only give a high five to
somebody that you believe in
that you're rooting for
that you're kind to and that you want to
see when
and what we've found based on
researching
this simple habit adding a high five to
the mirror every single morning you
don't say a word as stupid as it sounds
just high-five the mirror but we have
found after researching this for 18
months
and having
153 000 people from 91 countries do this
for five days
is that it has a profound effect
on how you speak to and how you see
yourself
because it is an action
that demonstrates to your brain that you
care about yourself and you support
yourself and so those are two physical
things that you can do
to start to shut down
and fight back against the critic that
is programmed into your head also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four choose your words
carefully with bruce pulver the power of
my words absolutely have an impact on
everything i do however
we are often taught that our word our
actions speak louder than our words
but what i learned in this moment is
that my words trigger everything
and if i pay attention
to the words i use i can more
effectively drive my outcomes
outcomes of my own
outcomes with conversations in
relationships and outcomes with
especially
my children
okay let's go through an example
you may be going through your bad moment
right now everybody has something going
on it might be catastrophic it might
just be how am i going to get home and
get back to work this afternoon because
remember i may left and i don't want to
be on facebook today so i may not be
here or shouldn't be here
let's you we can deal with things one
way or the other so let's go through the
either or example
so we're faced with some sort of change
okay
we can look at it
as can't handle
another negative gut-wrenching
experience or we can flip that
and we can say circumstances have
altered now get engaged
how does that vary with how we'll be
dealing with whatever that thing is
so we now have a
framework for how to deal with this
change this bam moment
however it's not that easy right
because what happens
mr fear jumps in
so we can look at fear
either as
i fail every attempt regardless
or
it fuels my energy and resilience the
fear may not go away
but how i decide to deal with it will
determine my outcome
okay great we've lined up the change
we've kind of got fear in the little
corner here at least temporarily
what about mr confidence
can say
can i
or just move the eye to the other side
and make the question mark an
exclamation point
and say i can
if we can do that
it moves us from being cautious anxious
nervous and insecure
too inspired confident affirmed and
never a doubt
doesn't mean we'll get there at the same
tempo in a straight line it does not
mean that we will get there without
obstacles but it puts our mind in a
place to be able to deal with that
change
every race has a last
lap right
every symphony has the finale
every author writes their last chapter
so what about that last bit we've got
framed up change we've got the fear and
control
we believe we can
but
it's really easy to tighten up to get it
across that finish line
we can either look at as petrified under
stress and helpless
or we can just put up some hard work
get ourselves self across the goal line
so what i've learned is a carefully
selected word
can save or change a life
can mend a broken relationship
can build confidence in ourselves
to be successful
i would like to leave you
with a challenge
a 30-day challenge
i challenge you to live an inspired life
how do we do that
invest in your possibilities do what you
can with what you have today
neutralize the naysayers
einstein is quoted and i'll paraphrase
as saying negativity can find a problem
with every solution
how about we say positivity can find a
solution for every problem
surround yourself with inspiration the
books you read the people you surround
yourself with
the music you listen to because that
will give you inspiration
put your yes in motion
start every
thing with you expect success
yes
insist you will then do
doing beats wishing
do hard things if you do hard things
hard things become easier to do
the batteries will go low
plug in
and recharge
when you do
you can elevate your energy
you always have another level you just
have to believe
and finally distribute your inspiration
to others
there's nothing more contagious
than inspired
life
your words matter rule number five stop
thinking about it with sadguru you take
away negative thoughts
don't identify any thought as negative
because it's just a thought
who told you it's negative
it's just a thought you're making it up
maybe you like it
what's the problem
if you understand it's just a thought it
has no power
if you think it's a reality
then it destroys you
it's just a thought isn't it
is it true that you made up the thought
no
ah it's you're having doubts about it
because
you are not thinking you have a mental
diarrhea happening
yes it's simply happening
thinking the word thinking means
you are exercising your thought process
consciously isn't it
yes
thinking means
you are doing something consciously
right now this is in a state of mental
diary it's just boring all the time
now
what is negative about it what is
positive about it what is negative is
it's happening unconsciously that is
what is negative not the content
you thought about the devil that's
negative you thought about a god that is
positive there's no such thing
it is the most negative thing that's
happening right now is it's happening
unconsciously that is what is negative
about it
and
a whole lot of people have destroyed
themselves
trying to stop
those thoughts that they think are
negative
and
they try to fight them in so many
different ways you
create these things and then you fight
them
[Music]
it's your thought
[Music]
you must be able to throw it and roll it
back whenever you want isn't it
you must be able to roll it out and roll
it in as you want but right now
your own ghosts have become so big
[Music]
that you want to fight them
if you win you're really lost
because something
that is not true
if you fight and win it
you have really lost it isn't it
so there is no such thing as negative
and positive thought
either it's a conscious thought or it's
a diarrhea
[Music]
so
how to stop this see suppose you are
having diarrhea
physical diarrhea
first thing to do is
every other treatment is next first
thing to do is
stop eating bad food isn't it
something cause diarrhea first thing is
stop eating bad food whatever caused
this stop that
this is the first thing you must do
right now the bad food is just this
you identified yourself with something
that you are not
now you can't stop your thought process
do what you want
you do any mantra you want think of any
god you want do whatever the hell you
want the moment you identify yourself
with something that you're not
you cannot stop your mind and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus clips is don't resist
negativity with jim quick the goal is
not to stop it completely a little
self-criticism can be a good thing give
you a reality check that motivates you
to be a better person but there is a big
difference between i need to read more
and saying things like i'm not that
smart i am not good enough i have a
horrible memory so studies show that
negative self-talk is associated with
everything from higher levels of stress
to depression so what do you do with
your negative self-talk first
here's two things you do not want to do
you don't fight them and you don't fight
for them what do i mean about don't
fight them what i mean by that is don't
try to resist doing these things because
as you know what you resist persists if
i ask you not to think of a big purple
giraffe don't think of a big purple
giraffe don't think of a big purple
giraffe what do you do you see that big
purple giraffe in front of you right so
don't resist it don't fight them and the
other thing is don't fight for them
don't fight for them a lot of people
they're always fighting for their
limitations they're talking about how
they can't remember things they can't
remember names they're so overloaded
they can't keep up and here's the thing
if you fight for your limitations you
get to keep them if you argue for your
limits you get to keep them
so how do you stop beating yourself up
and replace this negative self-talk you
could do so using the magical words
abracadabra abracadabra
you know the word abracadabra is derived
from an aromatic phrase that means i
create as i speak in the hebrew language
this phrase translates into it came to
pass as it was spoken you know words
indeed have power as a memory aid i want
you to remember the first four letters
abra a
b
r
a
the a stands for acknowledge acknowledge
that it's there don't resist it remember
what you resist persists
the b
in abra stands for breathe
breathe take a breath now
[Music]
control breathing not only keeps your
mind your body functioning at their best
you can also lower your blood pressure
promote feelings of calm and relaxation
and help us to be able to de-stress
breathe in what you want and then the
third step is the r is release release
what you do not want you can't lead a
positive life with a negative mind so
you want to as you exhale exhale that
breath out and let go of the limitations
let go of the hurt let go of the
helplessness and finally the last a is a
line a line use your imagination and
create a new phrase or a new belief that
is more aligned with really who you are
and what you really want it might be
something like i have a great memory i
learn things quickly and easily my focus
is my gift i really do have a quick
brain the magic trick is to go beyond
just saying it you really want to
experience it you want to go in and see
it step into this new belief and see how
it really feels
so again when you want to replace the
negative self-talk that holds you back
remember abra acknowledge
breathe
release and align to what you really
want
do this and you will unleash the magic
of your quick brain
so as you guys know entrepreneurship is
tough it's one of the hardest things
you're ever going to do in your life and
there's so many ups and downs around the
business that if you lose your
positivity if you start to get negative
then it's going to be really really hard
to keep your business going because you
need to be that force you need to be
that positive person that's infecting
others to go and do this impossible
thing that nobody thought was possible
to do right you need to have that
positivity because if you give up
everything crumbles so today i'm going
to talk about seven ways that you guys
can use to stay positive even when
there's craziness and crap happening all
around you
so number one is belief no surprise
coming from me it's important to believe
in what you're all about and believe in
the mission and believe breaks down to
me is believe in what you're doing so
have passion right whatever project
you're working on you need to believe in
it you need to have the passion behind
that project it's believing yourself
having the confidence to know that you
can do this and believe that it's going
to work out to have the conviction to
keep going and to follow through at the
end of the day what really helps is
remembering your why what is the big
thing that you are trying to accomplish
with your business with your idea
because that can help you stay motivated
because sometimes you get so lost in the
weeds of the day-to-day grind that you
forget about the big purpose the big
mission that you're on for me
remembering why i'm doing this what the
reason is behind something that can help
you get through those hard times those
dark days so believe and remember why
you're doing this
number two is create a great environment
it's super important that you have an
environment that makes you come alive
that builds you up that lifts your
spirits that makes you believe that you
are you know the best version of
yourself and so i'm filming here in my
office you can see some of the stuff
behind me right you've got steve jobs
here and howard schultz here my parents
here and there's other famous
entrepreneurs on my wall i want to
create an environment that i walk into
and i feel enriched and i feel happy and
it's hard to walk in like i'm working
here this is my desk i'm working here
and i've got like
these people looking at me i walk into
the room and i've got these people
looking at me and it inspires me right
and that's me like you may look at that
and say that's really stupid i don't
want to have those people in my wall
that's creepy to have these big faces up
on the wall whatever it is right that
helps me and so creating an environment
that makes you come alive think about
what's on the walls what's on your
computer what's on the phone background
what apps do you use right like what's
around you who are the people in your
life what books do you read what are the
videos that you watch what are the
things that are around you that help
build you to be the person that you
could be because you know the feeling if
you're around negative people if you're
watching the news all the time you're
gonna start feeling really negative
where if you're surrounded by positive
things uplifting things resources that
build you up that give you ideas that
make you feel creative that make you
have confidence that's so much better
for you it's better for your health it's
better for the creations that you'll
you'll put out and it's better for the
world and so don't make your environment
something that's just happens to you by
accident consciously create it for
yourself so you've made an environment
that helps you be the best version of
you
number three is help someone it's really
hard to feel down to be negative to have
a bad attitude when you're helping
somebody else out and so a great way out
of the dole drums is to help somebody it
could be somebody in your business it
could be a customer could be a partner
it could be an employee it could be you
know supplier but it could be somebody
on the street it could be the person
behind you you know in starbucks pay for
their coffee right and just something
holding the door for somebody something
where they would appreciate it could be
a handwritten note to somebody it
doesn't have to cost you money it
doesn't have to cost you a lot of money
or any money it just takes a little bit
of time and a little bit of awareness
and appreciation to find somebody in
your life that you know or you
you're about to know
to find a way to contribute to them in
some way that makes them feel good and
when you make somebody else feel good
naturally you just make yourself feel
good
even going on the comments of this video
and responding to some of the other
people who've left comments makes them
feel good right recognize them
appreciate them thank them for their
insights that will make them feel good
but in that process it makes you feel
good too so if you're ever feeling down
or negative a quick way out is to help
somebody
number four is improve your habits just
like the environment that you're in is
super important so are the habits
because you are what you consistently do
so what do you consistently do do you
engage in negative habits do you engage
in things that bring you down or do you
engage in habits that are meant to build
you up so what does your morning routine
look like what does your evening routine
look like what does your schedule look
like on a day-to-day basis is it
something that helps build you up or do
you just fall into it by accident
because you're so rushed to get through
the day right if you don't have 10
minutes to spend on creating an ideal
schedule in life for yourself or 10
minutes in the morning to center
yourself then you don't deserve to have
the great things you don't deserve to
have an amazing life right spend the
time you have 10 minutes to focus
yourself
and so what are the habits that you are
doing consistently what does your day
look like consistently so for me
i wanted to have more greatness around
me right and so i put the habit of
watching the videos every day
i made the top 10 videos and espresso
videos for me selfishly because i wanted
it i wanted to be around these big name
entrepreneurs who've done big things and
i watch them and i get inspired because
it's so easy to be complacent it's so
easy to wake up and just fall back into
your usual habit and routine where here
i watch somebody doing something bigger
man i i gotta go out and do something
bigger myself and i need that every day
because i'm all pumped up and excited
today on wednesday filming day for you
guys jacked up super excited tomorrow
i'm gonna wake up and it's starting all
over again so i need to have something
in my morning routine to get me fired up
again to help me push beyond my safe
comfort zone to something that makes me
do something that's new and scary and
different and exciting and so what are
your habits what do you do consistently
what is your morning routine is it
engineered
for you to be a success instead of you
falling into it by accident create
positive habits
number five is have accountability it
can be really hard to
only be accountable to yourself because
you'll tend to do the things that you
just want to do and not push yourself to
where you could go and i think as
entrepreneurs it's especially hard
because we don't have a boss right yeah
you have a customer who may be pushing
you on a deadline okay great you work
hard to get that deadline down but
otherwise you don't have a boss you get
to make all this into yourself there's
nobody pushing to say hey you could do a
lot better and so having an
accountability partner having a
mastermind group having a place where
you can share your goals and have people
hold you accountable to them and even
just putting it out in public post on
this video go to the comments and say
some of your goals and what you want to
accomplish within the next month what do
you have on your radar what are you
trying to accomplish right even just
posting it up
makes you feel a little bit more
accountable and that's important because
you will tend to let yourself down too
much
we won't let other people down you'll
show up for that meeting you'll show up
to go to that gym class if somebody else
is there with you because they're
counting on you to be there you won't
let other people down nearly as much as
you let yourself down so use that to
your advantage
and partner up with people and you can
help them too right this ties into the
other point about helping each other out
you can help them stay accountable on
their goals and if you know that you're
meeting this person next week and you
you haven't done the thing you said you
were going to do
you're more likely to
bust into higher gear to make sure you
get that thing done because you don't
want to let them down and so use that
hack to help you get the stuff done that
you need to get done have more
accountability
number six is be grateful and talk about
positive habits one of the things that i
do
every day in in my team is we have a
private facebook group where we talk
about three things that we're grateful
for every day so every day you log into
facebook and you have to add three
things that you're grateful for and it
may take you two minutes to do but it's
really hard
to hold gratitude in your mind in some
negative or angry thought
and some of the things we you know are
grateful for they might be a big thing
like i might be grateful for hayden i'm
grateful for nina i'm grateful for my
parents grateful you know live in this
beautiful city have this life that i do
and some of them are more esoteric like
i'm grateful for the internet you know
i'm grateful that alex brought me a
coffee today you know i'm grateful that
i have my own clothing line now i can be
grateful for a lot of different i'm
grateful there's a sun shining on me
today there's a beautiful day outside
right
if you take a couple minutes not just to
write them down but to actually feel it
to feel the gratitude to feel the warmth
of the sun to feel the love of your mom
to feel you know if you have kids or
pets or plants that you know that you
really love to feel that then it's
really hard to feel that gratitude and
be negative about something at the same
time it's really hard to hold that in
your head let me ask you guys one of the
things i'm thinking about doing is doing
a live stream
every weekday morning
maybe 10 o'clock i haven't figured it
out for 10 minutes
just
expressing gratitude for me to share
three things that i'm grateful for the
same three things that i make my team do
but then for you guys also to share some
of the things that you're grateful for
you can join me on the journey and join
me in the ritual that every day we do
this together and share the things that
we're grateful for i'm thinking about
doing it as a live stream in the channel
really curious to see what you guys
think if you like that idea or not
because it's had a profound impact on me
if you look at the research around
happiness it always comes down to
gratitude it's not about the money you
have with the car you have the job you
have or any of that stuff it's about
being grateful for what you do have
that's consistent across all the
research and so it's had a big impact on
me it's had a big impact on my team you
know i'm always looking at how can i
help you guys how can i help the
entrepreneurs out in michigan or ohio or
australia wherever you guys all are from
that i can't connect with you one-on-one
to do this thing where we spend 10
minutes together expressing our
gratitude for the day let me know do you
guys want to do it is that interesting
to you do you feel it's too fluffy bs
hokey pokey not interested let me know
because if enough you want to do it then
then i just might do it so curious leave
that in the comments below so that's
number six be grateful
and then number seven is live your one
word it's super important that you know
what you stand for and that you start
living it because chances are if you are
unhappy if you're not satisfied with
what's going on if you are a negative
constantly it's because too many things
in your life are not aligned with what
your one word is all about and your one
word is finding for me it's believed but
for you it's likely something else it's
figuring out what you stand for as a
human being what is the most important
core value to you it's what my book is
all about what is the most important
core value to you and then how can you
build a business and a life around it so
that is congruent for you so that doors
open more easily for you so that
decisions are made more easily
understanding who you are and what you
stand for makes everything a lot
smoother and easier compared to just
reacting to things and reacting to other
people's agenda set your own and so
again if you are unhappy with something
if you're not satisfied it's likely
because too many of the things in your
life
are out of congruency with your one word
you're doing too many things that are
not aligned with who you are as a human
being and so understanding what it is
that you stand for and then building a
life and a business around it really
dramatically improves the chance of you
being happy positive but also having a
huge impact and creating something maybe
even way bigger than you thought you'd
be able to create so live your one word
and if you need help trying to figure
out what that is you can always
pre-order the book it's a great read i
guarantee but even if you don't
understanding who you are what you stand
for and living a life around it will
dramatically change your life how do you
ever like get offered parts like where
you play something totally different
like a like you know what i mean like
you're a con you're a concerned father
and you're in a divorce and like it's a
real soft role and you just don't want
to do it his daughter got kidnapped and
now he must save her no no that would
probably be the same
no but i mean something that's so out of
the box for you do you get offered that
stuff mathematician that's going through
a bit of divorce
no i don't get offered though so
did you want to do one or not
not really you know
i mean
i only want to do things that i think i
could do a good job at and i think
i'll be no good at that really no i just
you know i'm not an actor really i mean
i i used to you know work jewelry and
pinch jewelry on this remodeling
you're right uh you know as a sportsman
for years i'm not really
some thespian that can adopt and
chameleon himself into different roles
i just got into this by you know being
at the right place at the right time i
was you know working working in the
street selling jewelry and i got plucked
from obscurity
into the movie industry so it's not like
i spent years
honing out do
different accents or pretending out you
know i accept what i'm good at or if
well i might not be good at any of it
but i accept what i feel that i'm
confident at and uh just try and go with
the flow in that direction most of us
have situations where there are for all
of you listening a place where you have
some unfinished business
that's the story of my life tony
okay well having a story of all our
lives right it's just being human right
but it's it's a place where there's
something that you should have handled
and you haven't handled with a person or
situation it stresses you out and so
what we tend to do is focus on other
stuff because we don't want to have to
deal with that because it's stressful
because it's you know that's painful
and so think of something that on a 0 to
10 scale where 10 is totally stressed
out and zero's not at all pick something
that's unfinished business in your
business or personal life with something
or someone and it's at least a seven
eight nine or a ten just so you can see
that this really works now by the way
there are hundreds of ways to do this
i'm just going to give you this one
because we can do it in two minutes
right
so
i'm hoping that tim do you have one by
chance i do tell you the content okay
give me a tell me the content no one
else tells the content all right
everyone if you would just for a moment
i don't have any music in the background
which i do to enhance this normally but
let's just do it both your hands on your
heart
and physically breathe deep into your
heart
[Music]
and as you're breathing deep in your
heart
feel the strength of your heart
feel the power of your heart
feel the beauty of your heart
what are you
proud
or grateful
that your heart has guided you to do
or to give
or to feel
or to enjoy
[Music]
and feel the strength of heart breathe
into it feel the blood flow the oxygen
and feel grateful for your heart first
because think about it
you didn't have to earn this heart
it was given to you you didn't have to
prove your value or your worth you
didn't have to accomplish anything
something loved you enough to give you
the gift of life
as long as it's heart is beating
you have that gift and you live
it beats a hundred thousand times a day
pumps blood through sixty thousand miles
of blood vessels we put them end to end
they go around the earth twice at the
equator that's what's inside everyone
else
you don't have to think about it what a
gift
so as you breathe in your heart feeling
your powerful heart
i want you just for a moment we're gonna
think of three but just think first of
one event in your life one experience
one moment
that you could feel so grateful for if
you wanted to
a magic moment
a sacrifice moment sexy moment a
beautiful moment a loving moment any
moment
really you could feel grateful for if
you wanted to right now and then step
into that memory from that
like step in your body as if you were
there
see what you would have saw
as if you're there i'll hear what you'd
hear back then
breathe the way you were breathing back
then
if you filled up with that sense of
gratitude for that moment
how do you smile when you feel so
grateful you're so thankful
[Music]
what's the look in your eyes how do you
breathe
let's look in your face when you feel
really really grateful
just fill it up fill up with gratitude
the reason we use gratitude by the way
is the two emotions that mess us up most
is anger and fear
and you know you can't be grateful and
angry simultaneously it's the antidote
you can't be fearful and angry
simultaneously
so fill up with gratitude and now think
of a second moment you can feel truly
grateful for and again breathe deep in
your heart
feel that power
just think of any other moment it could
be from your childhood or adulthood it
could be last week could be today it
could be 10 years ago
any moment that you could just truly
feel like that was grace that was
magical that was beautiful that that's
magnificent something that gives you the
feeling of tremendous gratitude if you
really focused on it
breathe it feel it
[Music]
enjoy it
fill up with gratitude
then finally think of a third moment you
can feel truly grateful for
step in it see it feel it be there
feel the gratitude what were you so
grateful for what are you grateful for
[Music]
and then maybe throw one extra one in
think of a coincidence
you know we all love when life happens
for us it's not to us we love
coincidences because we didn't do
anything something happened for us you
were going to do one thing and you met
somebody that you developed a
partnership with or became a friend or a
lover or the love of your life or
maybe a business opportunity came from a
coincidence
or an insight came from a coincidence
that's been so valuable in your life
something you're grateful for what's a
coincidence that led to something you're
so grateful for
and feel the gratitude for that
[Music]
it wasn't a coincidence or were you
guided
[Music]
now as you breathe in your heart you've
been doing this for about two minutes
keep breathing keep feeling it feeling
grateful
let's use this state to solve the
problem state
so the easy way to do that is
keep breathing your heart stay out of
your head in your heart
and think of that situation that's
unfinished business that stressed you
out in the past but keep breathing this
beautiful state and ask yourself this
question
ask yourself all i need to focus on in
that situation all i need to focus on
all i need to remember is what
your heart knows
all i need to focus on i'll need to
remember all i need to do in that
situation is what
your heart knows the answer
all we need to focus on all i need to
remember
all i need to do is
and then your heart probably knows the
answer i've done this a million times
not every one of you but in normal room
i'd have some people say raise your hand
if you've got that answer
98 99 people usually do even with this
simple technique you've done magazines
you've done movies you've done
television have you ever wanted to
release a cd of music oh honey please no
no i you know what i think one of the
things i learned growing up watching
other people like johnny carson for
example was um was a mentor in a way
because he always understood what he
could and could not do
and i truly understand
that that is not something i could do i
mean i attempted it just as a fun thing
a couple years ago run on run-on i got
sick of hearing myself that's why we
that's why we cut it off i wished i
could it's the one thing i wish i could
do but i think it's a gift to be able to
sing and that's not one i was given
but since i was given so many others
you can't do that you'll mess it up
you'll never get it right you're just
not good at that i want you to change
that voice to a cheerleader
a parent who dotes on you a teacher who
thinks you are the best thing in the
world and i want you to hear that voice
saying yay you can do it you're amazing
this is your area of excellence you're
good at this you know if you're a kid
running a race at school you'd want your
parent to be going come on come on
you're brilliant you're amazing if you
were doing an assignment at school you
want the teacher or your parent to go
you're very smart you're really good at
writing this is your skill set
so i want you to become a loving parent
to yourself a praising teacher a
cheerleader that always goes yes you can
do this this is easy this is a walk in
the park or you have the skills the
talent you've read that book you know
the answers you've studied
so that's how you stop being your own
worst critic flip it over and if you're
saying i always mess it up start to go i
get it right i always forget things i've
got a great memory that's the most
important listen whatever you want to do
in your life you got to kind of leave
your comfort zone the friends the family
the cousins that you hang out with all
the time that know you for who you are
you're saying this is who i may be today
but man i want this life and for you to
do this you got to leave them behind do
you know how many friends i had that
when i was deciding to go and spread my
wings this was the one line you ready
here's a line hey pat so have you made
your millions yet
pat thinks he's gonna be a millionaire
guys where's the millions huh i used to
see you drive a ford expedition now you
come with a ford focus you're definitely
becoming a millionaire it looks like
you're going backwards more than
anything i remember all these stories
every one of them i went from a big ford
expedition i'd go to all the parties
everybody would go in my car and we go
together i lost everything 49k in debt
and boom i pull up an afford focus that
i can barely fit in everyone would say
this is the guy that's going to be a
millionaire you're the guy that's going
to be somebody we should follow and do
business with give me a flipping break
and i was hated by my friends for five
years because i have to leave them
behind you want to come with me let's go
you don't want to come in no problem i
got to go do what i got to do you ain't
never going to pay my bills and i'm not
paying your bills i got to go do my part
i have to go out there and do it it is
not an easy thing to do but if you're
watching this you're going through it if
you truly are serious with the effort
backed up to it go out and get exactly
what you want
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven ways to stop your negative
thinking check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there there's a little bit of background
on myself too i'm currently going
through this in the microwave one of the
things that i've challenged myself is to
restructure my thinking around there is
no such thing as a bad day i'm trying to
really embody that